présidentielle de 2024 au sein
du Parti républicain.
Une soirée tout en fanfare pour
le solide deuxième mandat de
gouverneur de Ron DeSantis.
- Freedom is here to stay.
- "La liberté, dit-il,
est là pour rester".
Voilà qui enchante ses
partisans, qui veulent le garder
encore pour quatre ans.
- I'd like him to stay in
Florida for the four years.
- I'm Ron de Santis.
I represent the 6th
congressional district
of Florida.
- Le républicain de 44 ans a
commencé sa carrière politique
en 2012 comme représentant
au Congrès. Engagé dans l'armée,
où il a servi en Irak et
à Guantanamo, il est aussi
diplômé de l'Université
de Yale et de Harvard.
- Some breaking news right now!
A Republican, another Republican
is jumping into the Florida
governemnt.
- Mais en 2018, il démissionne
du Congrès pour tenter
sa chance au poste de gouverneur
de la Floride.
- Everybody needs
to support Ron DeSantis.
- C'est là qu'il obtient
le soutien de Donald Trump,
alors président.
Iprprprend alors tous les
thèmes chers à Donald Trump
dans ses publicités électorales.
Où il met en scène sa famille.
- Make American Great Again!
- Élu avec seulement 0,4 %
Où il met en scène sa famille.
- Make American Great Again!
- Élu avec seulement 0,4 %
de plus que son adversaire
démocrate, Ron DeSantis et
Donald Trump sont deux hommes
au diapason, jusqu'à en avoir
les mêmes postures.
Habitué de Fox News,
le gouverneur républicain parle
toujours de son cheval
de bataille : la liberté.
- We will not let anybody
lock them down.
- Il refuse ainsi de confiner
les Floridiens pendant
la pandémie et il déteste
les masques.
- Honestly it's not doing
anything. We got to stop.
- Même pendant ce point de
presse, lorsl l l critique
ces étudiants.
Sa croisade républicaine
l'amène aussi sur le terrain
de l'éducation.
- Unfortunately, we've seen some
books somebody's library.
- Il fait bannir des livres
des bibliothèques qui parlent
des orientations sexuelles
et donne davantage de pouvoir
aux parents d'élèves sur leur
éducation.
Tout comme Donald Trump,
une de ses cibles préférées :
les médias.
- Picking on the corporate
media.
- Il se permet ici de donner un
petit cours accéléré sur comment
les rererere à leur place.
- Wrong, it's a fake narrative!
Sa femme Casey lui donne aussi
un coup de pouce sur le terrain
lililitique avec des publicités
très efficace pour rappeler le
passé de son mari au service du
pays, son amour de la famille,
mais aussi son courage et son
aide quand elle a été frappée
d'un cancer du sein.
Aujourd'hui en rémission,
elle galvanise les foules
aux côtés de son époux.
Cette récente publicité
électorale où il se présente
comme un combattant que Dieu
a créé le 8e jour est des plus
surprenantes.
- So God made a fighter.
- Il n'en fallait pas plus
pour que Donald Trump, excédé
par la popularité du gouverneur,
se moque de lui.
"Ron le moralisateur",
dit l'ex-président, qui se fait
talonner de plus en plus par
DeSantis pour l'investiture
à la présidentielle dans 2 ans.
De Santis n'essaie pas de cacher
certaines ambitions.
"La Floride, dit-il, offre
un plan que d'autres États
devraient suivre", selon lui.
Mais, loin des tumultes
politiques, sur le bord de
l'océan, ceux qui se disent
plus à gauche ne sont toujours
pas vendus aux républicains,
ni pour Trump, ni pour DeSantis.
- If I had to choose between
either, I wouldn't vote.
- Celle-ci ne voterait
ni pour l'un ni pour l'a...
Ron DeSantis visera-t-il donc
bientôt un coup de circuit en
sautant prochainement dans la
grande arène présidentielle?
Les paris sont ouverts.